So as we have discussed before, camera is basically, is trying to
capture a 2D view of a 3D world, to an essence, it's a window into a 3D world.
But of course, in the case of the, camera, the world is 3D, so here for
example, the train tracks kind of give you a sense that as you go further away
things are getting smaller and smaller, gives you concept of perspective.
In this case, by just not looking at that side but
just looking at this side, I get less sense of perspective, same image but
just moved on to the side and showing the train tracks.
This is an important part again, how viewpoints and
field of view play into photography.
So imagine this is my subject, and my camera is here, I'm focused on
the subject except now this is my field of view from an 85 millimeter lens.
I can move closer, use a 50 millimeter lens and
still capture approximately the same details of the same subject.
I can move even closer, and use now a 20 millimeter lens and
actually have approximately the same field of view, but
I really kind of moved up a little bit.
We will see how this impacts our scenes, that we want to capture also.